so I'm gonna start off by saying just
upfront that I acknowledge how much
positive comes from technology I've been
involved in helping to build this just
look around us
Stanford everything that we have because
throughout the talk some of you who are
in the room or not in the room are gonna
be thinking yes but and thinking that
I'm not giving both sides well this talk
is not about all the positives so I'm
just saying it one upfront that I'm
acknowledging that there is lots of
positives and some of us see different
positives and others so I may bring up
issues that I think are less positive
but again starting off it acknowledging
it and I think that also those people
who have looked at the slides online or
to see the word digital pollution
immediately think that what I'm going to
talk about is all of the digital toxins
that the the content itself is the
pollutants and actually the term digital
pollution and I will get into this later
is more a metaphor for how to think
about this area and how we move forward
with solutions in the notion of
pollution having to do with byproducts
of industrialization or byproducts of
progress and as with industrialization
where we are now seeing dire
consequences of the costs that come with
that progress I believe that we have
similar problems with our digital
progress and the application of
digitization so that's what I want to
talk about today and I'm going to do
this in three pieces first I just want
to talk a little bit about digitization
because I believe as I just mentioned
that it's as profound a shift as
industrialization was so we like to on
one hand we often think there's nothing
new ever we've always we've been through
this before we'll figure it out again on
the other hand there are times in which
we have more significant shifts
often caused by some new type of
technology and I think we are at that
point again as we were as we moved into
industrialization and notice I keep
using the word digitization I'm not
talking about specific technologies here
I'm talking about how we apply digital
technology so it's about the
technologies and the use and the
business models around them that are the
issues here and not necessarily just the
technologies themselves sorry I realized
I'm holding this the second part is
after I talk about digitization I'm
going to talk a little bit about digital
pollution what are the issues and how I
think we might think about moving
forward and then I want to end because
we are at Stanford and to talk about
what is our role as technologists what
can we do and what can't we do to help
solve this problem so just two slides on
my background not gonna go into in
detail but one of the things you'll see
filtered through this is we very much
are products of our perspectives and so
I just want to give you a sense of where
my perspectives come from most people
see my background and know of me as an
entrepreneur and perhaps my board seats
involved with Disney or FedEx and as CTO
of Cisco but I've had experience with
innovation and across across all three
sectors so yes my career was primarily
entrepreneurial starting a lot of
companies had exposure to the corporate
world and then had exposure to the
academic and nonprofit world through
both my own work I'm an academic brat I
might both my parents were involved in
the academic world and through advisory
work and and the board at KQED and
Boop's
and then I can't I can't talk about
informing my perspectives without also
mentoring that I'm
of a millennial who doesn't like to be
called in a millennial but certainly of
you into the use of technology of that
generation through my son so somewhere
around the mid-2000s around 2005 I
stopped actively running the companies
that I was building I kind of picked up
my head was able to look around a little
bit more because I wasn't in an intense
operational role and as I did that I
also started to think more about the
consequences of some of the technologies
that and the industry that I was
involved in and that began with my book
in 2008 called closing the innovation
gap which one of the main points there
was that our innovation ecosystem was
off balance that we were reaping the
seeds of so much that we had created but
we weren't planting new seeds that we
weren't investing in the long term we
were becoming more short-term focused
then in 2014 I gave a TEDx talk that was
calling it was called balancing our
digital diets one of the things when I
look back at that talk is that I
actually have a statement in there about
lies moving faster than the facts that
can correct them and little did I know
then how big an issue that that was
going to be so again seeing at that
point it wasn't just our innovation
ecosystem but new digital technologies
such as social social media and others
were coming into the into the fore and
last year after the with the election in
2016 with all that has come out about
whether it is privacy issues our
democracy issues I won't go into them
right now it was an awakening of this is
serious this is not just ok we need to
think about this we need to start
waking up and so I have two pieces that
I've published on this one that's called
authoritarian technology and that is not
technology by use by authoritarian
governments that is that our
relationship with technology is
authoritarian it's unbalanced it is
submissive in terms of a boolean
controlling relationship and when I say
our I mean us as users I mean us as
society and the checks and balances that
typically that need to go along with new
products so as I was thinking about how
to to kind of kick off why what is the
issue here
why is this what is it about our culture
that is so impacted by by digitization
and I started thinking about all of the
words that we use our lexicon whether
it's in Silicon Valley or throughout our
culture that we now think of as good and
whether it is scale speed disruption
measurements tracking data driven all
the words that you hear every day not
just in tech companies and not just in
other businesses but nonprofits who want
to be more and more data-driven and
impact driven or campaigns that need to
be all data driven so across the
spectrum these words have now become a
lexicon for our society as have the
things that we think they're in service
of or they are in service of but we all
think of as good whoo-hooo questions
productivity efficiency convenience
impact profitability no friction all of
those things we normally would throw
around these words and it's like good
that's all goodness but at what cost and
that is what I want to talk a little bit
about so I was very fortunate to start
my career in the 70s at the at a time
when digital technologies and
information technologies were helping
Enterprise decision making and that was
really the first broad use of computer
technology and and enterprises were able
to make better decisions to improve
their products customer satisfaction
employee contribution so if you think
about the 70s and the 80s and then what
the Internet and the web came in and we
added into that very powerful means of
consumer outreach of content
distribution that's the point at which
individual adoption of these
technologies took hold and then the next
phase I I would say we've moved to if
you look at our technologies today
essentially a total infusion of content
processes and behavior so it's not just
about how we read things or how we get
in information but it really has become
completely integrated with how we live
our lives now along with that those
transitions were also a transitions in
the incentives in the market and if we
go back to the 70s and 80s companies
were judged on profit and often even
fundamentals people investing in
analyzing companies actually understood
the companies and looked at the strategy
and the fundamentals we then move to a
point in which really it was about a
measure of growth and in some ways as
the the markets became more automated
more data-driven then it became easier
to just measure gross it's harder to
kind of understand the nuances of
fundamentals if what you're trying to do
is do computer program training as
opposed to humans making those
recommendations and then somewhere along
the line we switch to growth wasn't
enough it was about momentum it was
about ever in
creasing growth and so the companies and
the people making decisions are being
driven by incentives that are that are
influencing them to just think about
growth and momentum and dominance above
all so why do I normally when you see
the increasing power and slides that we
show usually we like up arrows why do I
have a down arrow because I feel that
with this has come a slippery slope that
has created some of the problems will be
seen and in that last bucket as the
technology shifted in terms of our how
we use it how infused it is in our
culture there's also been a paradigm
shift in the culture in the way we think
about technology and the way frankly
technology companies are run and and the
decisions that are being made so from a
tech perspective what are the things
that have created this this shift it's
the things we know it's social it's
mobile it's cloud sensors in the
Internet of Things artificial
intelligence now one of the interesting
things about all of these technologies
is that they all play into a world where
they enable scale but scale drives an
advantage with each one of these
technologies so there's no question that
scale and the amount of data that you
have is going to enhance certain types
of AI that cloud has to do with scale
and scope and speed and so we're at a
time when there are other ways to
implement these technologies but the way
we're implementing it means the big get
bigger the paths that power begets more
power now I mentioned that there's also
been a shift in the culture if you go
back to
the the 80s one of the my favorite
quotes from Steve Jobs was him telling a
story of how technology should be like a
bicycle for the mind and that's because
someone had done a study of locomotion
of different mammals and I think the
Condor was up front on top and humans
came in at like 17 but when a human was
riding a bicycle all of a sudden they
were number one and so he used that as
an example of what technology can do for
us and can do for our minds but
somewhere along the line we started
hearing the luminaries of the valley not
talk about bicycles for the mind but
talking about software eating the world
and every company is a tech company and
there became this shift to to dominance
to a more aggressive type of stance we
in this time moved from an open
philosophy and open systems philosophy
that drove the internet and the web to a
more walled garden proprietary
philosophy now many people will say but
look at how open we are today and how
much we use open source open source is
not the same as open systems an open API
is not the same as an open systems
philosophy where people can can play
collaborate together as peers as opposed
to me having the power and yes I will
let you access that power or rent that
power temporarily where you are
dependent on on me platforms and network
effects became a big issue and how
people were driving their companies what
power they were building the moats
whether or not a venture capitalist
would invest in you so focusing on where
you can build those lock-ins became
decisive factors in the companies that
that could be that were funded and how
they grew and that leads to increased
consolidation the business model shift
to free consumer services where the user
is not paying any money it's free but we
have less power because we're it's very
different than when you are a customer
who is paying dollars now again not all
the companies share all of these and I'm
not talking about a specific technology
or a specific company but when you look
at the major companies and forces out
there
they shared different characteristics
here the co-opting of peer-to-peer
distribution community personalization
why do I say co-opting because these are
again all things that we've been told
are good for us but what they're doing
is propagating a model of data data
consolidation but not just data data and
knowledge because it's it's the
aggregation of this data and the ability
to turn that data into knowledge that is
really so powerful and that has become
the currency that has become the power
and through while this it's suddenly as
I was thinking about it I realized how
we've always talked about how important
creative destruction destruction that
was that select creative disruption is
to our economy is to our society well it
feels like we've shifted from creative
disruption to narcissistic disruption
meaning the disruption that's being done
is for the benefit of the disrupter it's
not benefiting the people whose problems
are being solved not that they don't get
any value from it that's not what I'm
saying but if you look overall the value
is more again accruing to those who are
disrupting and whether it is disrupting
society or disrupting the the news
business or disrupting yet another Indus
it's not clear that society overall is
benefiting from that disruption and
along this whole time we basically have
lost our ability to have any checks and
balances and I believe as I go around
talking to whether it's individuals
academics people in government people
and nonprofits there's an inevitability
to tech and actually we in the tech
industry have created that narrative and
we make things go faster and faster and
any progress is good progress but if you
put tech on a pedestal then there are
not the checks and balances that you
need for for society we talk a lot about
unintended consequences but the fact of
the matter is a lot of the issues that
arise are not just unintended
consequences but consequences of
intended use and so through this time
some of the new techniques that have
turned people into users whether it's
gamification creation and recommendation
is so critical because we've got so much
information you open up the floodgates
you have lots of choices
all of a sudden making a sense of all of
those chubsters becomes a harder and
harder issue and predictive AI as a as
it is applied to curation and
recommendation has a lot of positives
and a lot of side effects that will come
back to micro-targeting the ability to
go what Madison Avenue would have just
died for it's so beyond a focus group to
have that ability to not to to target
ends a zone in and get immediate
feedback on that behavioral capability
as along with the techniques our culture
of how we develop and our methodologies
also have impacted what we're doing so
agile we all need everything's moving
faster we need to be flexible we need to
be more agile at its extreme it can
create a level of fragmentation that
makes it so that it's harder to think
through consequences because we're not
thinking of things as a system we're
moving very quickly to to implement our
single piece the the minimal viable
products iterating on things a lot of
the the culture that started in startups
as lean startups and having a lot of
benefits when it's taken and put on a
pedestal and applied to things where it
doesn't belong you can again lose system
thinking and end up not not having the
strategic elements that you need for
different industries
couple that with moves fast and break
things that it's easier or even better
to ask for forgiveness than to get
permit then to get permission you know
all makes sense when you're building a
software startup but you can't just say
oops I broke democracy and you can't
undo harm when you're talking about
lives or elections and so there are
areas that you cannot apply the same
type of culture you need a different
type of system when you're talking about
the implications being as dire as they
are and then just to last on the culture
as we've moved towards maximizing speed
and scale and organizations we've also
been going through a period of time
where we've thought a lot about
diversity and how do we get more
diversity in organizations and then
people wonder why we haven't really
moved the needle well I would argue that
organizing for maximum speed and scale
actually works against homo
heterogeneous diverse environments
because when you're moving really
quickly and
you're growing very big it has to be
more formulaic it becomes more
hierarchical and it it works against
making it more diverse I think one of
the best ways to sum up the the the
valley today or the way Tek and and
humans interact is the notion of
friction so from an industry perspective
we want to make everything frictionless
I mean and that's a mantra mantra make
it frictionless build an app and take
all the friction out of something if
you're a large platform automate
everything remove any barriers to
onboarding content onboarding users
including making it free engagement and
addiction being yes I meant to say
addiction but focusing on engagement
which leads to addiction is another form
of that in terms of just taking the
friction out of people using your
product more and more now this plays in
to our human nature to desire
convenience we want what we want and we
want it now but you may want to eat
potato chips and ice cream all day but
you probably don't it just because your
taste buds are addicted to sugar and
salt because there was a time that's
what we ate your mind kicks in and you
decide that you're going to eat whatever
balance you decide you're gonna eat so
this this desire for convenience if we
don't understand the consequences or if
we're so addicted to something we shut
down that cognitive friction that comes
in is a dangerous combination there is a
difference between freedom and
individuals and getting what we want and
and doing what we want and free fall and
the fact of the matter is that friction
is not a bad word the right amount of
action is critical whether you're riding
a bike and the brakes are walking down a
hill and if you try too hard to avoid
friction you end up with hard stops you
end up with overcompensating and things
like rules and norms are the guardrails
are the friction you need for a
functioning society impulse control is
friction inside of us you can't work
through a relationship without some
amount of friction tolerating borden
boredom effort pain all is involves
friction and I've worried that actually
what happens if we the next generation
or the generation after that has evolved
so you work to avoid any effort to avoid
any friction because we get so focused
on convenience as as a value and that is
really dangerous you're going to become
a parent that's hard there's all sorts
of things that we can talk about that
way and the risks of unbridled
capitalism are amplified because of the
scope and pace of what is going on in
this area
ok so I've had people come up to me and
say ok so this is about privacy right
how do we get these companies to be more
transparent or protect our data and not
have identity safe well you know what it
isn't just about privacy and it isn't
just about being addicted to one's phone
it is a broader set of issues and one of
the reasons I decided to jump in a
little bit more vocally in this basis I
think there's a lot of good work being
done on some of these issues again
whether it is addiction to phones
whether it is data privacy but it feels
to me like we tend to then get locked
into just those couple of aspects and
that there is a broader set
of issues here which involve economic
cultural intellectual and emotional
health our democracy in our national
security and they these things interplay
with our other big problems our other
big challenges be inequality the future
of work the future of our planet because
if we don't have a functioning society
or democracy if we aren't willing to
embrace some amount of friction we
certainly are not going to solve those
other problems I'm not going to go
through all of these in detail but
clearly I've mentioned loss of data
privacy is a big issue whether it is
theft or the way that data is being used
to target you addiction to phones and
video games is real and there's a lot
you can go read about it
mass manipulation in terms of marketing
it's been around for a long time
you now have platforms that just make
that much easier to manipulate by bad
actors sensationalization there's so
much noise we all then naturally just
yell louder to be heard and it
accelerates and accelerates and
accelerates filter bubbles that we've
all read about some of the things that
we don't talk as much about is the level
of anxiety and fear that these
technologies actually play into so we've
heard a lot about FOMO somebody asked me
what this other acronym is it's one I
made up which is fear of losing economic
or social status and that fear of losing
sometimes it's the loss of it sometimes
it's just the fear of that loss is a
fundamental problem that we're we're
seeing globally and and you could argue
that there there is a feed into what's
going on from a populism perspective
again technology and digitization is not
the sole cause of these things but it
it amplifies or isn't is one element in
the in the things that that I'm talking
about fragmentation we had if your news
comes at you with our different articles
through your feed interrelated with each
other with other news you don't have a
sense the same sense of context of where
that's coming from now you can say
there's a brand associated it's not the
way we're taking in this information so
we tend to take things in in fragments
and in that fragment you have a loss of
context and a loss of trust I would
argue that the world is flattening our
connectivity our communications we have
a loss of nuance that nuance is is
dimensionality that we don't have in so
many of our communications and
relationships the amplification of the
dark side of human nature is leaning to
just a basic loss of dignity and then
there's a propagation of all of our
natural biases some of which are okay
some of which are not okay in the
propagation of the data but there is a
deeper level of all of this that are
less obvious I would compare this to
what happened with the innovation are in
the food sciences to high fructose corn
syrup took us a long time to realize the
connection between that and diabetes or
obesity and I believe there are elements
like that going on whether it is
personal agency that comes from relying
comes from addiction or the fear and
anxiety critical thinking the ability to
not blindly trust or not trust anything
we're in a situation now where there is
a severe loss of trust in anything but
you need that combination of trust and
mistrust to be able to not either again
blindly follow somebody or not believe
anybody facts do exist and so does
authoritarian
propaganda and we need to not be in any
one of those things personal Authority
when you look at how the the AI driven
curation and personalization this is not
just a curation what's happening is that
you're in some ways your conscious and
unconscious behaviors are being fed into
algorithms and then and machine learning
and then you're being told what to think
what you like what to buy
now not everybody many people see that
and they're fine
they they they look at it they may
decide you know what I don't want to
just look at the top 3 things that
Amazon gives me I don't want to just
look at my newsfeed and I'm gonna go
explore I'm gonna ask I'm many people
will do that but a lot of people won't
and you become more and more driven to
accept what is being told to you which
is not paying attention to your own
unconscious but feeding that into a
machine that loops it back and tells you
what to think and so I believe that that
has a strong impact on over time our
personal Authority digitization of
everything everything is one-zero black
white you're for you're against this
again goes with the lack of nuance I can
listen to somebody and not agree with
them but maybe there's 10 percent of
what they're saying has some interest to
me but if I immediately go to the other
side then I'm I'm defending and I really
do believe that technology and
digitization is playing a role in how
that's developing if you do not have
critical thinking if you don't know how
to question and how to trust and you
have blind faith you're more open to
authoritarian leadership and whether it
is political professional your personal
social relationships
Dogma in religion you it takes personal
authority to have a balanced
relationship
and so again some people may say they
think that's the right direction but if
we believe in a society that we are
looking to keep democracy as the the
primary means and want balance we're
going in the wrong direction the impacts
are not just on us as individuals but
this leads into it it impacts how we
operate collectively so democracy
requires access to information common
facts and the ability to deliberate and
all the things I've talked about you can
have a sense of how that impacts our
polarization our fragmentation which
means we don't have a common context
we've ended up with essentially an alt
reality where we're questioning whether
facts matter or what is a fact
so misinformation disinformation all of
the things that we hear a lot about
today are are not just transient it's
not just about today it's about a
fundamental breakage in what we need for
a democracy to function and we really
need to think about that as this is not
a partisan issue critical problems as I
mentioned earlier whether it is climate
or an inequality require collaborative
action they can't be solved top-down and
they can't be solved without people
working together
if you oversimplify none of these
problems can be oversimplified or can be
solved with simplification if somebody
says to you we'll just give me a three
bullet answer well there isn't a three
bullet answer to to the things that that
we're talking about and it requires
people being willing to have to deal
with deferred gratification a lot of
these problems do not and actually have
the
their immediate responses backwards a
little bit or or more friction or less
convenience before we end up in in a
better place and something that we
suffer from here in the valley as much
as anybody is is what I call solution
ISM nobody wants to talk about anything
unless you can give them an answer so
don't tell me about the problems what's
the answer what's the answer what's the
answer well you know what sometimes you
need to talk about things for a while
because there are a lot of smart people
who are gonna come up with different
ideas and there isn't a straightforward
single solution and we as entrepreneurs
in the valley we're even more guilty at
about this because if you're starting
something new you focus in and as the
country and the world has put
entrepreneurship on a pedestal that's
the way we get everything done we
actually further drive a notion of
solution ISM I'm not saying that we
won't have solutions and that we don't
need solutions and you'll see in a
minute that I'll talk about incremental
versus long-term but you can't just
immediately say don't talk to me about
that complexity tell me what the answer
is or I don't want to hear about it an
organizational problem solving has the
same thing I this slide comes out of my
book when back in 2008 where I was
talking about what are the core values
of innovation what does it take to have
a capacity for change and I identified
through all of my interviews that it
really is a balance of questioning which
is curiosity as well as self-assessment
non-judgmental risk openness to imagine
to new ideas to sharing patients which
is tenacity and patient capital and
Trust trust in oneself and trust in
others and that you need to have a
balance of those in an environment to
create innovation you can't just pick
the one you like risk without
questioning is gambling trust without
questioning is blind faith
neither one of those things are a
healthy innovative environment and we
like to think about the internet and
technology as helping a free flow of
ideas and encouraging innovation well I
would suggest you think about all the
things I just talked about and I'm not
going to go through it but think about
how they map on to these core values and
are they enhancing them or are they net
creating a problem with our innovation
it's time to take this more seriously I
think you can tell that that's why I'm
standing here today and I think more and
more we're hearing that there are some
great calls to action out there I've
enlisted them all but a couple of the
books that just came to mind that I was
doing this from surveillance capitalism
which focuses on the business model and
how we got here - sucked which is the
story of Facebook more but more broadly
social media throughout your McNamee
book and the and there are a bunch of
others but one of the things that I find
with a lot of these books and by
definition when you set out to write a
book like this and come and and come up
with new ideas they are they're often
targeted but more importantly they are
advocating a very strong point of view
because you can't get people to listen
unless you are putting all the data
behind a single point of view now I
happen to like a lot of these books
that's why they're up there and happen
to agree with that point of view and I
have very strong points of view as you
can tell through this but I think we're
not going to solve the problems we have
if we just go to our corners and if we
take one strong point of view against
another strong point of view we have to
figure out how to get the collective
people involved in this debate which
includes the tech industry academia
government us as individuals it's a
broad set of groups to to talk and
figure out how to solve this because
it's not all good or all bad and the
term digital pollution which came from
an article that I co-authored with Sam
Gill who's with the knight Foundation
came out of a conversation we were
having about what is a model what is a
paradigm for how we solve this and if
you think about industrial pollution
industrial pollution is the the
recognition and it started in the 1700
and the recognition that there's a
problem here that there is a cost of
progress and then how do you resource it
how do you understand on an ongoing
basis the problems we created a field
environmental sciences which informs the
process so we're informing the process
with data and opinion so we have lots of
opinions we have lots of passion we also
have people who study over periods of
time what those pollutants are what are
the toxins what are dangerous levels of
those toxins and then we debate we
endlessly debate we move forward we go
backwards right here and now it feels
like we're you know backwards time when
it comes to industrial pollution but
overall it is a model that has at least
worked in a lot of areas to make it less
worse at least in terms of the cost and
a key part of this is that you measure
and assign a cost to the harm you don't
just celebrate growth you don't just
celebrate progress but you understand
the trade-offs so that's why we coined
the term digital pollution as a way to
think about this problem and so that we
can get people to not
again just talk about good or bad but
try to understand what are our values
what are we losing that we as a society
can't lose and what are the ones that
you know what we're gonna lose some of
that because it's worth it for the
progress we're taking now digital
pollution it's harder it's harder
because there's an accelerated pace it's
hard to keep up the level of the
paradigm shift we're probably similar to
the beginning of industrialization but a
lot of the work that's been going on on
industrial pollution we already
understood what industrialization was
all about I'm not sure we have the right
language a lot of the language and
existing rules that we try to apply
actually put us in the wrong direction
and some of the and the framing of the
questions may hurt us so we really need
to rethink that
but the tricky assiduous digital
pollution is unlike industrial pollution
where the byproducts are not useful they
are the chemical byproducts from a
factory are not something you want well
with digital pollution often the harm
and the good are from the same thing and
so it is really really tricky to figure
out how to separate those how do we
address this what do we do about digital
pollution again not going into detail
here but one of the main things is to
try to separate out the short term and
the longer term we need to be working on
both in parallel and in the short term
but not confuse the short term things is
thinking there long term solutions so on
the short term we need to mitigate the
damage or mitigate any potential damage
and protect the vulnerable so we need to
empower people with information and
tools we need to demand incremental
change from the industry and who's we
we as a combin is people and ultimately
people may be influence regulators but
if you can do it from movements whether
it's healthy food movements or clean
energy that put pressure on on the
companies this is easier said than done
and there are a number of areas where I
think incremental change can be done
without completely changing their
business models and we need to enforce
and adapt current rules when they're
applicable because there are many
current rules that just don't seem to
apply because we don't know how to fit
the current paradigm in but we need to
change the relationship we need to take
tech off a pedestal we need to address
the market dynamics and competition we
need a real checks and balances on these
companies we need a field of research we
need actively funding and not just
corporate funding of people who study
and identify where is the harm and how
harmful it is and we need to increase
the tech capacity in governments and in
civic society because we're off-balance
because it's complicated and you have
you know those people who watch the
hearings on the hill and just thought
everybody in Congress was just so
embarrassing because they don't know
what an iPhone is and that is the
reality TV part of the problem but it's
deeper and we really need to increase
that capacity and this is an opportunity
for human centered technology so let me
finish by as I mentioned talking about
our role as technologists and as we have
grown in power we we as an industry the
role of Technology on the world we have
not taken the responsibility that comes
with that power for some because they
don't realize it for others because it's
easier not to take that responsibility
so what can we do one I would challenge
everybody to
in the industry and and associated with
the industry to think how are we being
individually and collectively complicit
what is it that we're doing that maybe
feeds into the narrative the reason
digital filter bubbles work is because
we have psychological filter bubbles we
live in a world we hear that lexicon the
people we talk to and it's hard to that
that's then the perspective in which you
look at the world and so recognizing
that when you're reading things are
looking at issues and starting to
question whether the the things we
assume are good are all good or whether
there is only one way to do something
and that is maximum speed and maximum
scale we need to a lot of people ask me
whether I think industry people are bad
people and I think what we need to
realize is it's not intentional or
non-intentional there is such a thing as
unconscious intentionality that have to
do with our incentives have to do with
where we've come from
what are where we are in the power
system that unconsciously makes us act
certain way which is intentional but
it's unconscious intentional and and we
just should be really really aware of
that we need very serious thinking about
ethics starting efex for technology
industry for computer sciences but
starting with values it can't be just a
checkoff item and I hear a lot of
conversation about well the yes we need
to do ethics so we're gonna have a chief
ethics officer in this company or we're
gonna add ethics to this to a class but
not a lot of discussion about well what
does it really mean and what does it
mean for this industry and that takes
some some serious thinking we're so used
to celebrating
corruption and blowing things up and
institutions are bad and nobody wants to
move slowly well there are implications
for blowing something up if there's
nothing there in between people need
glue people need some type of friction
and things that tie them together so it
yes institutions need to evolve but just
blowing things up without knowing what's
going in their place doesn't work for a
functioning society and we we need to
keep people at the center as individuals
and as a society people talk about do we
need a user Bill of Rights
how about Human Rights we starting with
the fact that we're all users is
actually not going far enough economic
growth is important but measuring GDP
why are we looking for economic growth
it should be in the service of overall
well-being which is a harder thing to
have a metric on and let's always
remember that balancing power requires
ongoing vigilance very rarely do people
get power and then say I am enough power
I don't want more power or I don't want
to keep my power and so that's not a bad
thing that's that's human nature and
that's why you need checks and balances
whether it is a good friend that tells
you you're getting arrogant and knocks
you down to size a little or whether it
is checks and balances on large
corporations um one of the things
actually I realized I went past a bullet
there that which is we've got a lot of
assumptions and and norms in technology
and business that we take for granted we
just should reflect on which of those
ought to change and one of them is how
we think about metrics we worship
metrics the metrics are the way we not
only run companies but often it's the
way we run our lives whether it's our
Fitbit or the numbers that that
were using to drive us and we need to
realize that they can make us myopic
depending on what you choose but if
we're gonna measure harm also this is a
place where we need some really clever
people thinking about how do you measure
harm and how do you measure harm at
scale because potential harm is where do
you look how broadly do you look and if
you're again thinking from one
perspective it just may never occur to
you to look somewhere else
early detection which is another way
which is you don't you can't imagine the
consequences so you want to detect them
early well if you're doing that at scale
is an early sign an outlier or an early
signal and how do you detect that how
what do you throw out and then there are
so many interrelationships that if
you're focusing on one harm and you
decide I'm going to get rid of that well
that may exacerbate another one and so
being able to prou tire theis arm so
this is a hard issue but we've got a lot
of smart people and we ought to start
taking some of that smarts and applying
it to think about it one of the things
that I think we struggle with is that
how do you balance the focus and
simplification of the benefits of
metrics because part of metrics is
driving behavior and driving incentives
so you can't have too many of them
because you don't know what message
you're sending but for learning you need
more nuance and so some of the
organizations I've worked up we talked
about try to differentiate make sure
you're differentiating between metrics
and measurements measure a lot but don't
just throw it away make make sure that
you have mechanisms to go back to those
measurements and look at them at the
right time and then you can simplify and
decide what metrics at any given point
in time you want to be driving behavior
and then use the understanding you get
from that measurements to read
visit and change those metrics Tech
alone cannot fix this and it seems like
the rest of the world is looking to
Zuckerberg and saying how are you gonna
fix this and frankly the technology
industry wants people to leave them
alone and so there they want and they
care and they want to solve it but one
of my favorite quotes is an Einstein
quote that says we can't solve our
problems with the same thinking that we
use to create them and that's part of
the problem here tech needs to of course
be at the table but not dominate the
table so it's not even the case often
when I say tech alone can't fix it
people say well of course we as
technologists we bring in social
scientists and political sciences to
inform us but tech is still dominating
the table I believe we need to change
that dynamic and have a table that is
more even and why is that because in the
technology industry most people swim in
the waters of tech optimism and you need
you don't want to not have optimists but
you need to counter that and there is a
natural tendency for for the values of
the leaders of companies or the
ecosystem to to permeate the rest of the
ecosystem and this is a personal opinion
which is I believe right now the leaders
of much of that ecosystem tend towards
data ISM as opposed to humanism you can
make your own judgment I personally the
reason I'm standing here is I want to
see a world where the human is centered
but I'm not sure everybody agrees with
me and I'm concerned that there is a
concentration by definition because it's
the people who are pushing this the the
furthest in terms of wanting
a different balance there I think it's
really harder for those in power to
question what is keeping them in power
again human nature so we desperately
need a counter balance within tech we
need to learn how to zoom in and zoom
out a little better we've got to look
beyond what we can solve now and be able
to zoom out and look longer-term at the
bigger picture and then zoom in on
solutions and we need to take a
different approach to friction we need
to think about sacrificing some speed
for intentionality in many of our design
choices and how we and how we organize
things and I I would like this is this
is my idealistic slide which is I would
like to think that maybe we can rethink
our worshipping of scale and speed or
not that you don't want but how we scale
and how we move quickly in our
organizational design and our system
design because I think the way we're
doing it now the cost is just too high
pattern recognition which is part of
again scaling and speed is very
important in a lot of areas but we also
need to realize that strict pattern
recognition can restrict and that you
need there's a difference between
pattern recognition and context and
their environments where if everything
is strict pattern recognition we really
will respect restrict our view I
mentioned that hierarchy that scaling
fast has a cost in terms of diversity
I believe that formulaic organization
and leadership styles not don't just
cost us in diversity but cost in terms
of trust deep trust and power balance
because we're the more hierarchical it
is the more you have that power
imbalance so what
what I like to think that we would that
some of our design values would be
around real community not community
being used as as many connections as you
can to dignity and reciprocity we've
gotten away from that notion of
reciprocity so maybe we should scale for
deep trust maybe we should be thinking
about 180 people as opposed to 180
characters and groups in which you
actually scaling down where you actually
can have trust but then you interconnect
for common action and and what do some
of those organizations and and maybe
this comes from I'm giving away my
giving away my age which I already have
but goes back to being involved in the
early days of the internet and the early
internet had individual networks that
each were diverse did things in their
own way that interacted with each other
for collective or common action now
today's internet is not exact
it doesn't look not exactly isn't like
that but that Internet's scaled and it
provided diversity and it provided trust
and I think we ought to think about how
can we incorporate more of that into our
current design so I'll leave you with
these words again and would like to
think that maybe you'll look at them and
think about them a little bit
differently than when I first put them
up and that may be a word that isn't on
there that needs to be on is balanced
and that's really what we need to do we
we just feel so out of whack that what
we need to do is think about how do we
get more balanced into how we use
technology and as a society
[Applause]